IN EARCOMBINE
FORCES.
ARBROS.
LLBIGMOUNTTHEY ARE NOT T SZE, BU
PORTLI AND MOVIES, TV SHOWS,
OT WELCOMEMOVE, ON W
DISCOVERY IS DOWN 2%.
SCHILLER,E NOW.
ULBE DOING BUSINESS, SOMEONE
IN
LOOK.
TO SAY THIS DEAL IS HISPECULWE S
BY T WAY, DAVIS HASSLE OF,O
CEO BOB W THOSE HAPPEN BOBVISLYE
R.
THE IT, THERE
COMPMES PARAMOUNT IS MOSTL
THERTHE
LMERGER, ANTITRUSISND
THEN THE MARKET, AS YOU SAY.
A HERE.
>> RIGI NEED TO CORRECT E A TECH
PERCENT, THE GREMLINARE I APOLOZ
QUESTN S, WBC
DIAZODD BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF DEBCUTBACKSWIHOW ONTH -
PURCHASE, OR PAROU
>> TRUE, BUT THERET OF VALUE TF.
S NOW,BROADCT AS AN OUTLET F
THAT., OF
ROG ON,
GHT NOW.
IOBAN OPTION FOT OUAL LIKE TO ,
AS SE IS ATHO
TE DEAL.TER LEVAG
OUOF WARNER BR
D DISCOVERS TREMENDOUSAN NICKELG
IN ALL OF T
IS THAT FAMOUS PHRASE,
NOW THHEEHE COMPANY
E,
Y N
AY, AND OTT
OF THE WOODWORTOAT IT AS WELL.
W  COUISX
T MEANS
Y  SPRING TO
T, DO YOAGUNT IS NN >> OH, W A .
AND IF YOU ARE COMCAST NOFOU ARS
OUNYTHOK, PARAMOUNT, ESPECIALLYN
, WHEN IT IS ALL ABOUT
THE STG BE
, PARAMOUNTES NOT HAVE AS BIG AN
US
YOCOH DISCOVERYTIME WARNER'S MAR
ASY,
VERY ATTRACVE
>> RIGHT, BUT, BUT, AND I
THIS IS THE CORE
RTE
WHETHER IT IS
AIRLESBUT IS THIS TOO DRUNK ME
TR THIS UP? WELL, I N CAN'T SAYS
WELL AS , LEGACY MEDIA IS
DECLIN
THESE ARE LARGY LE MEDIA
OUTLETS.
VE INCREDIBL
WITH INTELCTUAERSHOWS, CHANNTHS.
E R
WARMTH IEXACTLS
NECESSRE.
>> THE ASSETS, I ALOOKIN
N.TH ABSOLUTELY
FORMIDABLE.
>>BL>>INE OA.CTRNER BERT
SIMPLY FORMIDABLE.
YES.
CRUISEBISTA PARAMOUNT GU>> YOU E
FLYICRTH LT.WATCHED THE LATE